it Chapter two clocked in at a whopping
two hours 50 minutes however the initial
coach was around four hours long meaning
the return of fascinating deleted scenes
fans never got to see yippie Kay movie
lovers I'm John and in this video I'm
revealing all the deleted scenes from it
chapter two and explaining the six our
directors super cuts that we can look
forward to my penny wise Funko pop
giveaway is still running so make sure
you subscribe and keep watching for more
details on that and of course spoilers
ahead
the trailers hinted an intriguing
deleted scene where Mike is taunted by
penny wise when he visits the burned-out
building where his parents died and the
world of it book reveals a lot more
details about the cut scene at the time
the town of Derry thought that Mike's
father had set fire to the building on
purpose because he'd lost his mind you
can see a hint of this in the actual
movie when Mike's in the library looking
at a newspaper headline that claims his
parents were crackheads in the deleted
scene when Mike returns to the building
he encounters penny wise who shows him
the burnt corpse of a little girl who
also died in the fire and the evil clown
tries to make Mike feel even guiltier by
claiming his parents were to blame for
the girl's death if they had included
this deleted scene in the final film the
truth about Mike's parents would have
been discovered after the losers killed
it for good this would have happened in
the closing scene of Mike at the library
where he would have noticed that the
newspaper headline now read to locals
died saving neighbor's daughter from
electrical blaze so with the evil curse
of it lifted from Derry
the truth that Mike's parents were
actually heroes who died saving a young
girl's life would have been revealed it
would have been great to see this
cutscene because all the other losers
visited a place from their childhood and
had an encounter with penny wise during
the film but this barely happened for
Mike other than that tiny flashback
after which he was attacked by adult
Henry Bowers there's an extended scene
of Beverly's encounter with mrs. Kirsh
at her old house the scene was already
pretty creepy in the movie but it was
cut down for time and in the trailers
some of the moments play out a bit
longer
Oh awesome music that clip wasn't in the
final film and the scene instead cuts
from Bev looking at the postcard to the
music already playing this trailer shot
of flies buzzing around the window as we
hear the music adds to the scenes creep
factor but was also scrapped from the
final film this also concept art in the
world of its book of an unused scene of
mrs. Kirsch transforming from the tea
making old lady into the enormous
grotesque witch that attacks Beverly the
art looks pretty amazing and would have
been cool to see in the film but the
filmmakers decision not to show the
transformation does make the giant witch
his sudden appearance more of a
disturbing shock there's another deleted
moment with Bev after she runs out the
building and into the street which would
have shown her being taunted by a bright
red balloon with the words
sweet dreams bevy there's a similar
scene in the book and nineties TV
mini-series were after rushing out of
her old house Bev is almost hit by a
truck and then is freaked out when a
yellow balloon appears out of nowhere
[Music]
Beverly also had an extended scene with
the mrs. Kirsch water monster that she
encounters when the losers end to the
cistern just before they go into
Pennywise isler the monster drags Bev
underwater and the other losers dive in
to help her out
however this deleted footage of the
battle underwater with the monster in
the trailers Jessica Chastain apparently
injured herself performing the stunts
for this scene so hopefully the entire
scene of the loser's vs. the monster
will appear on the blu-ray or in the
supercut chapter 2 introduces a pretty
trippy origin scene for it's with Mike
giving bill a drug that lets him see a
vision of how it arrived on earth and
slaughtered everything is encountered
however there was another scene of fact
story phoned for penny wise that
screamed briefly for test audiences in
Chapter 1 and which many expected to
appear in chapter 2 the scene was set in
1637 in a building called the well house
which later becomes a house on new book
street in the deleted scene penny wise
terrorizes a mother and her child by
shape-shifting into various forms in
front of her and then threatening to eat
her her baby and all of her other
children penny wise then makes a bargain
with her that if she leaves her baby for
it to eat
it will leave her alone driven mad with
fear the mother gives up the baby then
becomes hypnotized by the dead lights so
from then on she's immune to the horror
of Pennywise eating her baby and his
future atrocities the deleted scene was
alluded to in the first movie via the
painting in the town library of a woman
carrying her baby to a well a picture of
Bill skarsgård in an earlier human form
circulated after chapter 1 however it
looks like the filmmakers decided
against using that human form of
Pennywise in chapter 2 and instead had
him putting on the clowns white makeup
and tearing bloody red marks into his
face during the mrs. curse sequence
although chapter 2 brought the
adaptation of Kings novel to a
definitive close there has been serious
talk of a possible third hit film which
would delve much deeper into Pennywise
as origins and time and dairy before the
losers so it's possible the deleted well
housed scene could be revisited if that
third movie gets made also revealed and
the world of it book is an alternate
version of the flashback scene where Ben
is taunted by Pennywise masquerading as
Bev in the final film this happened back
at school but originally it was going to
take place at the quarry and linked to
this there's some deleted footage of
adults been walking around the quarry by
himself which also never made it into
the actual movie the book reveals that
stunt double Ciera Jones took the place
as a fear Lillis and war Byrne make up
for the flaming head scenes and it also
tells us that in the alternate quarry
set version of that scene after bed set
her hair on fire
penny wisest hand would have also burst
out of her chest holding Beth's beating
heart this does sound intriguing however
the school setting in the final film is
likely more atmospheric and darker as
it's set indoors and the locker part of
the scene also plays on Ben's
claustrophobia which was highlighted at
the start and end of the movie the
school setting is also a better fit for
Ben discovering his token for the ritual
of chert which is the page Bev signed in
his yearbook fans of the book may have
been somewhat disappointed at the lack
of explicit references to the cosmic
turtle from King's original novel
however there was a deleted scene in
chapter 2 involving the turtle at the
quarry in a call back to chapter 1 when
they were kids the surviving five losers
into the lake and there's an extended
version of this scene where the adult
loses swim underwater and encounter the
turtle that bill saw as a kid the turtle
director Andy muschietti has promised
that we'll learn more about the turtle
in the extended version of chapter 2 for
those who haven't read King's original
novel the tarsal is a friendly cosmic
entity that created the universe after
vomiting it up when it had a tummy ache
it's name is Mattern and as a being of
creation the turtle is presented as an
entity opposed to it who calls itself
the eater of worlds there are several
other michurin turtle easter eggs in
Chapter two which I discuss in more
detail in my ending explained video
there's a link to that in the video
description and also at the end of this
video as well as the scene I mentioned
earlier Mike had another deleted scene
with Pennywise in which the two of them
confronted each other about their plans
muschietti described the scene on the
press tour as introducing the idea of
belief as a weapon the cut sequence
played out like a chess game with Mike
saying we're going to get you now they
believe and Pennywise contradicting him
they believe in me this would have been
an interesting moment but I can see why
it was deleted as the idea of using
belief to defeat penny wise was touched
upon in particular at the end when Beth
gives Eddie the spike he uses against
the penny wise spider monster take it
big kills monsters Gus and in the final
film we see the losers harnessing the
power of belief to imprint their will on
penny wise and shrink him down until
he's weak enough to kill chapter 2 had
its first share of cameos including
Stephen King himself who reunited bill
with his old bike silver director Andy
muschietti in the pharmacy scene and
Brandon Crane who played young Ben in
the TV miniseries and returns here in
the scene featuring adult Ben's
teleconference with his architecture
firm however fantasy and horror legend
Guillermo del Toro who produced must get
his debut feature film mama almost made
an appearance in the scene of young been
running away from Pennywise at school
del Toro was going to play the school
janitor that Ben bumped into and of
course the scene would have ended up
quite a bit longer in that case but
sadly mesquita couldn't get schedules to
line up with the famous filmmaker
who's like Stephen King wasn't involved
in the first hit movie he really enjoyed
the film so for chapter two the
filmmakers sent him an early draft of
the screenplay for feedback the author
gave them a little list of things that
you would like to see in the movie one
of which was the Paul Bunyan statue
attack on Richie
which did make it in however in an
interview with io9 Andy muschietti
revealed that King had also requested
the inclusion of a scene from the end of
the book where the standpipe rolls down
the hill during the destruction of Derry
the filmmakers ultimately decided
against this a muschietti explained that
we didn't go in that direction because I
wanted to keep the ending more intimate
and more about the emotions of the
humans of this group still there is a
nod in the final film to the novel's
destruction of Derry went off to its
death the underground cavern and sewer
system collapsed and the entire new
boathouse falls apart into the sinkhole
below in Chapter two Bev manages to stop
the losses leaving Gary when she reveals
she's had nightmares where she's seen
them die if they don't defeat it during
the current cycle but there's also an
extended version of this scene with some
deleted footage in one of the trailers
where Bev seems to hint at how they will
die it consumes us from the inside
since we don't have a choice it sounds
like she was suggesting that if the
losers didn't deal with it now they
might end up like Stan consumed with
fear from the inside and eventually
driven to suicide or some other horrible
death after the release of chapter 1
producer Barbara muschietti said they
planned for the opening scene of the
second part to feature the black spot
which in King's novel was a club mainly
frequented by black customers in the
original script for chapter 1 there was
a flashback to the attack on the black
spot Club however that was cut from the
first movie and instead there was just a
brief mention when the young losers were
checking over Ben's research into the
history of Derry where they told us a
black spot was a nightclub that was
burned down by a racist cult it would
have been interesting in chapter 2 to
see if the black spot fire was connected
in any way with the fire that killed
Mike's parents in the end though the
filmmakers decided to open the sequel
with the brutal Adrian Mellon scene
which follows Kings book and also fits
well with a movie's new LGBTQ storyline
if you'd like to see many of these
deleted and extended scenes and the
great news is that Andy muschietti is
working on what he calls a supercut of
both it chapters 1 & 2 which he
estimates could be around 6 and a half
hours long as well as adding back in
many of the deleted scenes from both
movies muschietti is planning to film
two additional scenes one of which is
from King's novel while the other is
entirely new in fact one of those new
scenes will be related to a resolution
of the perpetrators of Adrian melon's
beating bringing some justice for that
crime miss-ghetti reckons that in the
Age of bingeing content fans will love a
six hour plus movie to watch either in
one go or split up into smaller pieces
in fact another possibility is that the
entire story gets recut into a mini TV
series that includes the original and
unused footage in a similar way to how
Tarantino did with an extended version
of the hateful 8 movie on Netflix by the
way if you'd like to see more called
chapter 2 bonus scenes concept art and
fascinating behind-the-scenes details
check out the world of it book links in
the video description below now which of
these deleted scenes would you like to
see in a supercut of it and would you
like a third movie about Pennywise is
history and dairy share your thoughts in
the comments and don't forget to
subscribe and hit the
aleem link below for a chance to win an
awesome penny wise Funko pop the
giveaway runs until the end of this
month and the winner will be contacted
via email tapleft to check out another
each video all go right for something
else you're sure to like if you enjoyed
this then unleash your inner movie lover
with more videos like this every week
thanks for watching and see you next
time you became movie lovers